comment est-ce que vous allez est-ce que
ça va aujourd'hui est-ce que tout se
passe bien pour vous aujourd'hui
regardez on parle de ça on parle de la
redmi pas de la Xiaomi redmi Pat qui
était présenté il y a pas longtemps
c'est une tablette de Xiaomi alors on
avait déjà parlé tablette de Xiaomi
l'année dernière mais là on se parle
d'une tablette très abordable un tarif
qui est canon qui est pas trop cher ça
reste toujours de l'argent ça c'est une
certitude mais par rapport à ce qu'on
retrouve ça reste très maîtrisé on se
parle ici d'une tablette qui est
disponible à partir de 279 € 99 centimes
pour une version 3 giga de ram 64 Go de
stockage et on se parle également d'un
tarif un peu plus élevé je pense plus
intéressant et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi à 299 €, 99 € pour une version
4 Go de RAM 128 Go de stockage autant
vous dire qu'ici on est à un petit peu
moins de 300 euros pour une tablette de
Xiaomi d'ailleurs pour une tablette de
redmi parce que je ne sais plus dans
quel pays Xiaomi et ennemi sont un petit
peu séparés c'est une marque ici c'est
Xiaomi qui le distribue redmi pad on
regarde ça on regarde si c'est
intéressant on y va vous êtes prêt c'est
parti
[Musique]
la reine d'iPad elle est ici alors je
vais passer très rapidement c'est
surtout ça la RnB pas de la reine elle
reprend un petit peu ce look qu'on
retrouve sur le Xiaomi 12 t pro shemi
12T je vous ai présenté l'autre jour
déjà on retrouve ici le petit branding
Xiaomi c'est une tablette qui est une
diagonale de 10,61 pouces la taille est
correcte et qu'on viendra parfaitement
bien je vous le dis direct Franz billets
c'est une tablette qui est là pour un
usage personnel autour du divertissement
autour de séries autour de films autour
d'email mais pas un truc de fou on n'a
pas énormément d'informations on a quand
même derrière vous allez voir c'est
quand même sérieux mais c'est pas la
tablette la plus folle du monde avant
toute chose je vais vous montrer un
petit peu le design alors il est évident
que sur une tablette un peu moins de 300
balles forcément on va avoir des
contours un peu grands ici à Xiaomi a dû
opérer des choix fatalement néanmoins
une fois de plus on en a pour son argent
et c'est très honnête ici alors elle est
disponible dans trois couleurs à vous de
voir laquelle pourrait vous plaire le
plus elle va être disponible en gris
anthracite qui est ce qu'on pourrait
appeler noir qu'on retrouve en couleur
noir sur le site de Xiaomi on a un gris
argent qui est beaucoup plus clair et on
a un verre menthe personnellement comme
elle est là je la trouve vraiment
extrêmement jolie le poids est correct
est plutôt bien réparti elle fait 445
grammes bon ok très grand standard ici
et après ce qui nous intéresse c'est
toute l'expérience de visionnage
d'expérience multimédia comme je vous le
dis tout se passe ici au niveau de
l'écran c'est du LCD ici bien évidemment
pas de haut là il faut opérer des choix
pour vous sortir une tablette
intéressante en termes de tarif on est
une résolution en 2000 par 1200 pixels
la résolution est correcte après c'est
vrai que lorsque vous venez regarder
certains films et certaines séries on
aurait aimé avoir un poil plus de pixels
vous voyez bon ok ça fonctionnera quand
même un taux de rafraîchissement de 90
Hertz et lorsqu'on vient fouiller ici
voyez dans les paramètres ici au niveau
du taux d'actualisation alors vous avez
le choix soit il est par défaut
recommandé ça veut dire qu'il va
s'ajuster façon dynamique soit vous
venez le personnaliser vous êtes souvent
90 Hertz soit en 60 hertz vous
choisissez vous directement vous
connaissez l'histoire assez exactement
comme sur les smartphones plus vous
allez pousser plus vous allez augmenter
le nombre d'images par seconde
c'est-à-dire le nombre de Hertz et plus
vous allez venir taper dans la batterie
ça c'est un truc à savoir vous le
laissez ici en personnalisé en
automatique ça fera le taf tout en
sachant que de toute façon lorsque vous
regardez des films et des séries vous
serez en 60 images par seconde de toute
façon vous avez pas besoin de 60 images
par seconde pour un film pour une série
mais bon vous serez là dessus en tout
cas après on va avoir différentes
informations au niveau du schéma de
couleur pour mettre en plus saturé si
vous le souhaitez en standard standard
c'est vraiment dégueulasse intense il
vous le mettre en recommandé ce que je
vous conseille moi effectivement c'est
de venir pousser le saturer si vous
aimez bien ça devient un peu plus
flatteur sinon vous laissez en intense
par défaut ça ira très bien on a notre
truc qui est intéressant c'est qu'on a
un mode sombre alors à la différence des
écrans OLED vous savez vous êtes déjà
expliqué lorsque vous êtes sur une dalle
OLED tout ce qui est noir sont des
pixels Ethan donc on vient économiser en
batterie sur du LCD c'est pas le cas la
LED va quand même émettre une lumière
donc on va venir quand même consommer
c'est juste une question de confort
savoir si ça vous plaira ou si ça vous
plaira pas donc vous pouvez être sur le
mode clair ou le mode sombre comme vous
voulez la luminosité on va venir pousser
ici au maximum regardez là je l'ai mis à
fond c'est sur du 400 litres alors on va
éviter de se mettre en extérieur parce
qu'il est évident que 400 litres à la
maison pour mieux regarder des films des
séries Cera bien vous êtes dans la rue
vous a un peu de lumière c'est galère un
autre truc à connaître sur cette
tablette c'est que je trouve fait la
dalle est quand même très réfléchissante
donc si vous avez une source de lumière
derrière vous allez la voir et ça peut
être un peu embêtant si vous regardez
avec une fenêtre derrière vous verrez
les reflets de la fenêtre donc venez
vraiment trouver le bon endroit qui va
être vraiment adéquat pour venir
regarder des films des séries et tout
ceci et tout ça là vous voyez je vous
mets un petit peu le reflet de ma
lumière qui est juste au dessus bon on
peut pas dire qu'on la voit pas on la
voit bien de toute façon on la voit
énormément alors ici on a un milliard de
couleurs et surtout on a une
certification SGS qui certifie que
l'écran vient lutter contre la fatigue
visuelle et ça c'est extrêmement
important parce qu'on sait que lorsqu'on
va sur une tablette et bien on vient
regarder souvent du contenu multimédia
donc on passe un peu de temps dessus
fatalement autre truc à coriatre ici
vous avez quatre haut-parleurs alors
regardez elle est haut-parleurs se situe
juste là un haut-parleur là un
haut-parleur ici et vous avez exactement
la même chose de l'autre côté un ici et
un ici alors le truc intéressant c'est
que lorsque vous poussez à fond il y a
du son très honnêtement le son reste
quand même assez médium on n'a pas un
truc avec beaucoup de basse et on est un
peu moins de 300 euros ça me paraît
quand même relativement normal je trouve
ça correct on a quand même suffisamment
de son et ça marchera très très bien
regardez je vais vous mettre un peu plus
loin vous allez voir vous voyez le ma
franchement il y a du son et c'est
complètement correct alors après si vous
voulez venir écouter directement non pas
au travers des haut-parleurs mais avec
un casque on est certifie audio donc ça
c'est vachement bien on est également
certifié irez audio wireless et en plus
de ça vous avez du Bluetooth 5.3 pour
venir vous connecter et appairer très
facilement des écouteurs après vous le
savez il y a pas de magie l'idée c'est
d'avoir de bons écouteurs pour venir
maximiser l'expérience audio tout en
sachant que si vous voulez venir
l'écouter comme ça et bien vous avez
regardé c'est écrit ici noir sur blanc
on les certifié Dolby Atmos ok bon rien
à dire là-dessus l'expérience audio est
correcte et une fois de plus un peu
moins de 300 euros on en a pour son
argent maintenant l'autre point qui est
important c'est la question de la
performance qu'est ce qu'on a sous le
capot on est chez médiathèque on a un
Hélio G99 qui a gravé en cyanomètre je
vous le dis Franck biais on n'a pas ici
ce qu'il y a de mieux en terme de
performance après ça va dépendre une
fois de plus de ce que vous allez
prendre en configuration alors cette
tablette elle existe en 3 en 4 et en 6G
de RAM ce qu'on retrouve en France
aujourd'hui sur le site de Xiaomi elle
est disponible en 3 et en 4G de rami il
est évident que le 6 giga de ram ça sera
quand même venu aider ça aurait été
quand même beaucoup mieux la techno de
RAM c'est de la les déder 4x qui est
assez standard mais c'est pas sous la
plus fou fou mais ce qui me paraît aussi
une fois de plus normal à moins de 300
euros et il faut également savoir que en
terme de stockage vous avez soit 64 soit
128 soit 256 en ufs://2 on n'est pas sur
les dernières techno mais une fois de
plus il faut mettre en perspective par
rapport au tarif donc bon ça sera
cohérent ça sera correct tout en sachant
et une fois de plus sur le site de
Xiaomi France vous la retrouvez en 64 et
en 128 Go de stockage on n'a pas ici la
version 256 dans les faits ça donne quoi
alors ça donne que si vous vous mettez
un film si vous mettez une série vous
êtes peinard ça marche très bien on va
voir que certaines transition c'est pas
extrêmement fluide par moment ça reste
très correct lorsqu'on vient naviguer
lorsqu'on vient se balader lorsqu'on
vient lancer également j'en sais rien
moi Spotify par exemple voyez alors il
faut le temps qu'il arrive hop et qu'il
s'affiche on lui laisse quelques petites
secondes il a finir par arriver il nous
manque des fois un côté un peu
instantané où on se dit waouh waouh ça
va extrêmement rapidement et c'est très
très rapide voilà c'est là où va se
jouer un peu la petite différence donc
on resitu un peu les usages multimédia
film série si vous voulez écouter de la
musique la musique tout ce qui va être
email pour naviguer sur Internet il y
aura absolument aucun problème quelques
petits jeux aussi attention quelques
petits jeux on va éviter de me faire
tourner des fortnite là-dessus c'est pas
du tout optimiser c'est pas fait pour
mais il y a plein de jeux du Play Store
auquel vous allez pouvoir venir jouer
vous divertir donc bon voilà un peu
l'ADN de cette tablette aujourd'hui
autre élément à connaître on a une
batterie on a une grosse batterie à
l'intérieur c'est du 8000 milliampères
heure se permettra de tenir facilement
le temps que vous voulez donc ça c'est
plutôt rassurant ici c'est une tablette
est compatible charge 18 Watts c'est pas
extrêmement rapide et Xiaomi vous
fournit un bloc de charge ça c'est
plutôt bien il vous fournisse un bloc de
charge 22,5 watts alors attention ce
22,5 watts et permettra de recharger ici
qu'en 18 Watts alors 18 watts pour
recharger 8000 Maurer il faut prendre
son temps donc anticiper cette question
de recharge prévoyez on n'est pas comme
sur un smartphone ou on sait qu'on a
besoin de recharge rapide et après on va
le débrancher en règle générale une
tablette comme ça elle va surtout rester
à la maison où elle pourra vous
accompagner un peu à l'extérieur mais
pas plus que ça si vous ne pourrez pas
la connecter au réseau cellulaire il y a
uniquement une configuration ici en wifi
Wi-Fi 5 pas de wifi 6 pas le wifi 6 du
wifi 5 mais une fois de plus un peu
moins de 300 euros ça me paraît normal
toute l'expérience logicielle après bien
c'est mewhite 13 qui va être basé sur un
Android 12 mewhite 13 pour pad donc on
va retrouver l'expérience Xiaomi qu'on
connaît ici votre menu sur la gauche
pour venir naviguer et ensuite vous
venez dérouler un peu le truc ici bon
voilà c'est très simple c'est clair
c'est évident si vous connaissez déjà
l'expérience de Xiaomi franchement vous
serez pas perdu deux autres éléments à
venir connaître et bien vous avez des
petites caméras si vous voulez venir
faire par exemple j'en sais rien moi du
zoom pour le travail pour la fac et pour
venir converser avec vos potes vous avez
une caméra de 8 mégapixels à l'avant
mais également à l'arrière qu'on va
retrouver ici qui est planqué vous voyez
bon de toute façon une tablette n'est
pas faite pour faire des photos c'est
vraiment plus pour le côté
conversationnel lorsqu'on veut venir
appeler des amis tout en sachant qu'ici
vous avez un champ de vision de 105
degrés donc pour venir parler très
facilement il y a absolument aucun souci
et vous le voyez une fois de plus ça
c'est un peu le point négatif de cette
tablette c'est que c'est vraiment un
miroir on voit bien les reflets de mes
petites lanières blanches on voit bien
mon écriture alors moi autant je me vois
très bien à l'écran mais lorsque je
regarde dans le moniteur vous voyez je
vois vraiment ce côté reflet alors de
face là je me vois moi un petit peu mais
faut dire j'ai une lumière qui tabasse
vraiment en face voilà c'est un peu le
truc à savoir ici c'est que elle
réfléchit un petit c'est vraiment voilà
le petit point de détail et je sais pas
si pour vous c'est important ou alors
pas du tout après être très honnêtement
je sais pas si vous êtes comme moi moi
j'utilise beaucoup la tablette lorsque
le soir j'étais à la lumière je me mets
dans mon pieu et j'ai envie de me
détendre je me mets un film une série
c'est vraiment l'ADN de cette tablette
ici et je vous le disais on a deux
configurations en France c'est la 3 giga
de ram 64 Go de stockage à
279,99 c'est pas du tout la config que
je vais vous recommander pourquoi parce
que déjà 3 Go de RAM ça reste quand même
un peu juste et puis le stockage 64 Go
c'est pas énorme c'est pas très grand et
au bout d'un moment on risque un peu
d'être emmerdé ce que je vous conseille
moi c'est la version 4 Go de RAM 128 Go
de stockage ici vous aurez de quoi
stocker vous aurez suffisamment de RAM
on aurait eu 600 quand même été mieux
mais bon 428 à 299 € 90 ça me conviendra
beaucoup mieux ça ira très très bien
donc cette redmi pad elle est bien elle
reste cohérente par rapport à la gamme
redmi qu'on a chez Xiaomi on est sur un
produit plutôt d'entrée de gamme au
niveau des tablettes mais un produit qui
reste cohérent et avec une fabrication
qui est assez élégante j'aime bien
l'idée du module photo que je trouve
très joli après vous avez le bouton de
volume vous allez venir et là le bouton
pour l'allumer pour l'éteindre elle est
simple elle est efficace elle a quatre
haut-parleurs personnellement je trouve
séduisante et intéressante donc si vous
avez un budget en dessous de 300 euros
vous aimez la marque Xiaomi que vous
voulez rester dans l'expérience mi-white
13 et bien vous avez si une tablette qui
est cool c'est la redmi page je vous dis
point négatif elle réfléchit un petit
peu trop je sais pas si vous verrez bien
là vous voyez pour autant si vous
l'utilisez comme moi quasiment dans le
noir ça ira on va éviter le lendemain à
l'extérieur on va faire gaffe au
contre-jour mais sinon le taf sera là
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez ce
qu'elle pourrait vous tenter cette redmi
pas de ce que vous avez regardé
d'ailleurs ma vidéo sur le Xiaomi 12 t
pro je vais sortir mon test très bientôt
il y a déjà la prise en main puis
surtout on a fait un truc très cool avec
Xiaomi on a fait un escape game on a
emmené les Xiaomi fans se balader en
utilisant les services Google je vous
invite à venir voir cette vidéo si vous
l'avez pas vu parce qu'elle est vraiment
extrêmement cool et puis nous on se
retrouve très vite bien évidemment pour
continuer de parler de Xiaomi mais pas
que de pas notre marque ça c'est
chouette allez je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt Ciao
[Musique]